race is going to play a central role in
this case I'm off the grid for August
but fear not CNN is still a far left
activist organization pretending to be a
journalistic outfit
so Eric you're down in Georgia there are
19 defendants some of whom are very
Georgia specific here with that many
defendants do you think that that
everyone on that list is going to want
to play hardball with prosecutors or How
likely is it that someone would want to
cut a deal
I think it's extremely likely that
there's going to be a deal cut and I
want to make one more point if I may
unlike the other cases race is going to
play a central role in this case in all
kinds of ways we all know Donald Trump
is probably a little more sensitive to
black women than he is to other people
and um you know the Fulton County jury
pool is going to be largely
African-American if it stays here so I
do think there's an undercurrent of race
in this case especially given that it's
Georgia that's going to make it a little
bit different than the other three cases
I do expect some of those witnesses to
turn and to testify against the
president ex-president